the 1,300 active satellites above the
earth provide a wide array of services
some of which are vital for emergency
response and for the military
an attack on our country satellites
could be catastrophic and many worried
that space may become a new theater of
war large powers have developed various
capabilities for destroying satellites
[Music]
now companies are building advanced
service spacecraft that could become
weapons the purpose of these service
craft is to repair and move existing
satellites but all it takes is a change
of intent for these spacecraft to become
war craft a Chinese space weapon test
which destroyed one of its own defunct
satellites in 2007 created a great deal
of debris that put other satellites in
danger
if debris from one act of destruction
goes on to destroy further satellites a
chain reaction cadencia rendering some
orbits unusable this is known as the
Kessler syndrome
because America's armed forces gain more
capability from satellites than any
other country America has the most to
lose from war in space it is planning to
increase its capabilities in the area
president Trump wants a new space force
the world will hope for peace in the
cosmos but history suggests that such
ideals are not easily maintained
[Music]
coming up next Thursday why are humans
going to Mars
[Music]
you